The 21st century is being shaped
by heavily by technology.
In fact,
technology has always has always been
very powerful,
powerful forces in history because it
sets the context and information and
communications.
Technology definitely shape our year or
they connect people,
they make ideas and information more
transparent and open.
They can topple regimes.
I fully believe that communism ended in
eastern Europe because people became
aware that they had choices and we're no
longer ready to settle for the local
option and therefore support those
regimes.
So technology can have very,
very powerful social impact,
political impact,
and set the context for everything we
do.
I don't know
whether people,
humanity has an overarching purpose or
direction,
but I do know that we connect with one
another and that are legacies lie in
what people remember us for later.
I think we feel alive because we're
alive in the minds of other people and
therefore that might drive us not toward
the selfish side or the reptilian parts
of our brain fight or flight and
defensive reactions.
But I think that idea that our identity
comes from being known to being cared
about by other people.
Should drive us to attempt to make more
people aware that we have something
great to give to them.
So part of my personal philosophy I get,
so part of my personal philosophy also,
I guess,
is that giving helps you receive.
And that's what I believe our purpose
is.
I don't know about where that stands
theologically,
but I believe that we are in charge of
our lives on earth and,
and also that we have to play the hands
we're dealt.
I can't turn myself into some totally
different kind of person,
so I have to use what I have and if it
can resonate with other people,
then my identity is strengthened and
enhanced and they will remember me
afterwards wherever I go.
Then.